you
let me again site Badshah who's reputed
to have said that when a was given a
Nobel Prize that he could forgive the
man who invented dynamite but I that he
took the most diabolical mind in the
world to invent the nobel prize for
literature and I grew a certain extent
because each has each swelled my
constituency it was already sufficiently
you know swollen because I was agitated
world stage one way or the other but it
really made life impossible ii
impossible it's with astonishment that I
discovered that I've actually completed
a new work you know ever since the Nobel
its I was sit down look at it like some
strange object oh did I never managed to
finish this you know so it's it's a
mixed the next place I me of course I
enjoyed having a Nobel Prize prestige
that goes along with it the money that
came with it in particular the typical
still AM to some extent impecunious
writer you know just struggling to make
ends meet so that's you know nobody is
going to deny that at all in fact that
they want to give it to me a second time
I'm standing by its receive it
you